>>> YOU KNOW, WE HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES.
BUT THE F.B.I. ISN'T
INTERVIEWING THEM.
AND ISN'T GIVING US ANY FACTS.
SO, ALL WE HAVE --
>> YOU'RE INTERVIEWING ME.
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING ME.
YOU'RE DOING IT, SENATOR.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
YOU'RE DOING IT.
THERE IS NO CONCLUSIONS
REACHED.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS
KAVANAUGH RESPONDING TO
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN OF
CALIFORNIA IN TODAY'S HEARING.
WE SPOKE TO RETIRED PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ AHEAD OF THE
HEARING.
NOW THAT IT IS OVER WHAT DID
HE THINK THE OUTCOME?
ALAN DERSHOWITZ ALSO THE
AUTHOR OF "THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHING TRUMP."
AND HE HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
YOU WATCHED THE HEARING FROM
BEGINNING TO END.
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT?
>> I WATCHED HER AND I THOUGHT
SHE WAS EXTREMELY CREDIBLE AND
I HAD GRAVE DOUBTS WHETHER HE
COULD WIN THE CREDIBILITY
CONTEST.
BUT HE MADE A REMARKABLE
COMEBACK AND HE REALLY
TESTIFIED IN A COMPLETELY
COMPELLING MANNER.
SO I THINK IN THE END THERE IS
A TIE WHEN IT COMES TO
PERSONAL CREDIBILITY.
SO HOW DO YOU BREAK THE TIE?
I THINK ONE WAY IS TO LOOK FOR
CORROBORATION.
AND HE HAS MUCH MORE
CORROBORATION ON HIS SIDE.
NOW THE BEST WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT CORROBORATION IS ACCURATE
IS FOR THE COMMITTEE TO CALL
THE OTHER WITNESSES.
AND LET THE F.B.I. CONTINUE
ITS BACKGROUND CHECK.
AND I THINK IN THE END, IT
WILL DO HIM MORE GOOD THAN
HARM.
>> Tucker: NOW WHEN WE SPOKE
YESTERDAY, YOU SAID THAT YOU
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CHOICE OF RACHEL MITCHELL FROM
MARICOPA COUNTY SEX CRIMES
INVESTIGATION OFFICE IN
ARIZONA TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLICAN SENATORS IF THEY
QUESTION CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD.
YOUR POINT -- WELL, WE HAVE A
CLIP.
I'LL SHOW YOU YOUR POINT.
>> SURE.
>> I SEE THE GREATEST ENGINE
OF TRUTH EVER INVENTED USED
EFFECTIVELY, CROSS
EXAMINATION.
I WORRY WE DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE.
THE WOMAN HIRED TO CONDUCT THE
CROSS EXAMINATION PROBABLY
RARELY EVER CROSS EXAMINED
ANYBODY.
SHE IS A PROSECUTOR.
I DON'T THINK SHE IS THE RIGHT
PERSON WHO QUESTION DR. FORD.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW YOU WERE
RIGHT.
>> I WAS CRITICIZED FOR MAKING
THAT POINT I TURNED OUT TO BE
100% RIGHT.
SHE WAS TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
INCOMPETENT IN TERMS OF ASKING
CROSS EXAMINATION QUESTIONS.
SHE HAS LITTLE EXPERIENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MAIN ISSUE
NOW IS WHETHER OR NOT SHE
RECOGNIZED KAVANAUGH
CORRECTLY.
SHE WAS NEVER ASKED WHETHER
HOW WELL SHE KNEW HIM, HOW
MANY TIMES SHE ENCOUNTERED HIM
BEFORE THIS.
HOW CLOSE WAS THEIR
RELATIONSHIP?
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT COULD
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
EVEN IF SHE BELIEVES SHE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH, SHE MAY
HAVE MISIDENTIFIED.
SO SHE JUST DID A TERRIBLE
JOB.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS
REALIZED THAT AND THEY CANNED
HER IN THE MIDDLE.
BUT IT WAS A VERY BAD CHOICE.
>> Tucker: SO CAN I -- THOSE
OF US WHO ASK QUESTIONS FOR A
LIVING SAT AND WONDERED WHAT
IS THE POINT OF THIS.
NOT THAT SHE IS A BAD PERSON
OR STUPID.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY
BEFORE.
YOU HAVE TESTIFIED.
WHEN YOU WERE ASKING QUESTIONS
OF A WITNESS, AREN'T YOU DOING
SO IN ORDER TO PROVE A POINT,
TELL A STORY, YOU'RE DOING IT
FOR SOME REASON, AREN'T YOU?
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE A THEORY.
EVERY QUESTION HAS TO BE PART
OF A TACTIC.
YOU ASK QUESTION "A" IN ORDER
TO LAY A FOUNDATION FOR "B."
SHE WAS JUST ASKING QUESTIONS.
IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO GO
ANYWHERE.
SHE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH OF A
POINT.
AND IN THE END, SHE
ACCOMPLISHED NOTHING.
>> Tucker: BRETT KAVANAUGH
DEFENDED HIMSELF.
NOBODY ELSE WAS.
OTHER THAN LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THANK YOU.
PROFESSOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU.